right so here I am I'm about to sit and
watch the Star Trek Musical
I won't lie I'm not looking forward to
it but I will give you my honest opinion
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
right so before I start watching it I'm
going to just recap
now I'm not excited about this but not
because I don't think Star Trek should
be doing musicals or not because I think
musicals are vocal or some other
nonsense I just don't like musicals I
will sit and watch your bang bang or
Charlie in the Chocolate Factory
Christmas don't get me wrong they're all
right
but I'm not a big fan I also have a few
little concerns that Star Trek is sci-fi
and sci-fi should have like rules and
that
um I'm not sure how they're going to do
this that it makes sense that all the
crew suddenly know choreographed dance
moves and all the words to a bunch of
songs that they've never heard before
and sing them sing them all you know in
synchron so it's gonna be interesting to
see how they do that if it's just some
sort of magical energy wave I'm going to
be a little disappointed
if it's some sort of alien telepathic
thing and it's an alien using you know
music to communicate or something okay
we'll let it maybe maybe we'll see but
we're gonna find out in a couple of
minutes I'm gonna give you my honest
immediate reaction
I just hope I can watch it all if I'm
honest
but let's see I'm going in with this in
open mind people
it's a risky move by the creators of
strange new worlds
but hey sometimes the risky moves are
the ones that pay off the most
so let's give it a try
I'm gonna point out there's going to be
spoilers ahead if you haven't seen this
episode
but my
so they're trying to transmit
communication through and naturally
occurring Subspace fold
it's not working
so
pelia's um Carol Kane's character says
have you send music through because you
know maybe it's a thing of harmonics
sound is sound
what difference does it make if you send
that to a rhythm and then Spock The
Logical Spock by the way the man that's
supposed to you know bases it's entire
thing on logic goes
hmm that's potentially an excellent idea
why
why would Rhythm and make any difference
in when you're trying to increase the
strength of a communication signal
just stop stranger always keeps doing
this
he keeps making these things this is
very clever it isn't this in the second
episode of the whole bloody I asked for
Asylum therefore all the laws of the
Federation don't count
bits and they've got how clever are we
what we thought of that
doesn't make any bloody sense
but wait
there might still be an alien in that
Subspace fold and this might still be
like a you know a psychic trying to
communicate with the crew thing in which
case
you know
we'll wait but that doesn't make sense
I think we're about to get the first
song
the first song is really cringy
[Music]
it all is okay it's confounding they're
singing [__] off
this is so confounding I can't help but
sing
well you could just just don't sing
just don't do it
first sounds really cringy I don't like
the first time
it's really like oh I don't know what's
going on I just have to sing and and
Spock being the first one to sing
oh God
the other thing is Cooks in this episode
again and now he's on like a um training
thing with number one
and all I'm gonna say is they really
start to run out of excuses to bring
Paul Wesley back into this and to bring
Captain Kirk into the series as much as
possible if this show does go beyond
season three which again I've heard a
rumor that it might not but if it does
how are they going to continue to come
up with these nonsense reasons for Paul
Wesley to appear if this can season
seven and like oh Kirk's here why
um because
just is
he left his wallet last time I mean
they're really gonna struggle
the spot just explained why they're
singing it and it's made me laugh
it's a musical reality that's been
created when they put the message in it
unlodged some Quantum instance foreign
if that's the reason that is
that's beyond techno bubble that's a
freaking nonsense
oh please fill out the new sidekick
something or other involved in this
ah they've created a bubble of reality
in that reality everybody knows all the
words to these songs and I'm pretty sure
they're gonna dance together as well in
a minute
[Laughter]
and why are we confessing our deepest
darkest secrets
because this reality is forcing us to
behave
by the rules
of the musical
obviously
I like that they've thrown in a little
bit of actual Jeopardy now
the Klingons been affected by this wood
annoy them so that is that is logical I
like that this is the you know they're
going to attack the source of their
dishonor oh that's good and that you
know if they actually five Torpedoes at
this thing it's gonna wipe out half the
Klingon Empire and virtually all the
Federation so we've got a bit of
Jeopardy in the episode in this episode
is good
um and that is clever they've now though
crack down with another song
hmm
I really like nurse Chapel's character I
think she's
kind of hot to be honest fancier a bit
but her song is pretty cool
um I quite like it's more me I'm the
tapping my song to it
um I think her voice is is really really
nice and it's just a really cool voice
uh Jess Bush yeah I'm I'm loving this
song More Than I'm enjoying the rest of
them the rest of the song's been quite
cheesy and a bit cringe-worthy but this
song
don't remember that
just to think about the look this is
science fiction right so anybody that's
going to roll their eyes at this point
now
I don't care to be honest because this
is science fiction so just because you
say Quantum a lot
and loads of things in quantum physics
are technically true that doesn't mean
they are and but they've thrown a lot of
like Quantum words at this episode which
actually don't mean anything but
for this to be happening all of the
crews now have to be cyclically linked
all right because they all know what
they're about to do they all know where
they also this reality is somehow
generating the music
unless they're somehow
generating the music together again
psychically so again this reality has
now made everyone psychic apparently
um
they're all dancing together and I think
again they all know what everyone else
is about to do
there is no sciencey reason
that this is happening
and just because you tied up the
Heisenberg compensator which I do quite
like that because it's almost like they
know there's no science reason for this
right they know it's a nonsense
but the writers have gone ah but the
Transporters are a nonsense somebody
pointed out that it goes against the
Heisenberg Principle which basically
means you can't know where every atom is
At every moment Etc so we just we just
created the Heisenberg um compensator
and that fixed that problem so
it so just ignore it
I'm like okay
you're referencing that this is stupid
buying pointing out the transporter
thing which is a long-standing
right back all the way back to TNG
um thing in the transporter technology
the Heisenberg compensator
I quite like that
but
this isn't science fiction
it's just not
okay we just got to Uhuru
Celia Rose Gooding by the way can sing
the crap out of that so that'll mean
that was dear God that she can sink but
anyway
the answer to the problem how to stop
the singing
more singing so they're obviously now
going to have a big theatrical finale
that's going to get this um figure over
the 400 Mark which is then going
to break the quantum and probability
barrier
um a or sounds good
it's utter nonsense but it sounds good
um I I keep I I
this this episode is awful it's making
me laugh because of the this is science
fiction we're gonna throw Quantum words
at it and then that'll make it all fine
foreign
yeah the Klingon just started dancing
yeah that's how to ruin an episode in
one scene
the Klingons just started doing
um a boy band moment
so
the big finale song first of all they
did a old
um Gap advert which I mean there was the
spinny scene and all the crew started
dancing I was like yeah that's like um
an old Gap trailer from from the 90s
pretty bad the thing the song isn't
great it's okay I was expecting a big
Bohemian Rhapsody version which I
honestly would have been really cool you
know I actually have like a good song in
here that would have been great the
song's been okay that'd been bad but
yeah
and then they just did the Klingon bit
and I know I know that's supposed to be
funny
it's not
there's been some seriously cringy bits
in this episode
and
but nothing bad nothing really like
Jesus God what the hell
and then that Klingon bit and I knew
they were gonna do something like this
because when we saw the Klingon earlier
is the gold patch and all the gold or
everything I'm like that that looks
weird that's not a Klingon we've ever
seen before that looks strange but now
it's a Klingon boy band
that that has actually made me angry
that's a really bad bit that's not funny
that's just stupid this whole episode to
be honest is stupid okay it's made me
laugh in a few places because of the
silliness of it but I'm like willing to
put that to one side because at least
they're doing something different it's
not science fiction we can that boat
sailed a long time ago but all right
but that's actually bad
looks stupid
okay well the episode just ended
what do I actually think
it's a waste of an episode
so it's the ninth episode of the season
a season of ten and I argued this when
this got announced my main problem with
it is that this should be the first part
of the you know build up to the finale
episode
so it does feel like a bit of a waste of
an episode of Star Trek we only get 10
episodes of this
we've already had the crossover episode
which is the silly
um you know risky experimental episode
we only get one of them really but we've
already had then also the Spock as a
human episode which you know I'd argue
is a similar sort of thing
we've had three experimental episodes in
this series that's too many
the series The episode actually wasn't
bad
um in the I thought the songs were okay
I thought the story was actually well
thought out it's not sci-fi there is no
scientific basis for what happened in
that episode it's an absolute nonsense
um and just because they throw lots of
quantum words that something doesn't
mean get so
so no not science fiction
the Klingon bit at the end wasn't funny
it was just embarrassing stupid and then
they did a Klingon Enterprise dance
sequence where the Klingons katinka
class in the Enterprise's own little
dance
stupid
on the whole
sometimes I get a little bit embarrassed
by
my the things I love I'm a man united
fan if you're a regular soundtrack
you'll know that because you watching me
live and we lost seven years but when I
cried life
um and sometimes man united do things
that embarrass me
um on a personal level because I love it
so much I'm a man united fan so when
they do something like that it is like
this it actually affects me personally
I'm also a Trekkie
that episode of Star Trek embarrassed me
I I think it's embarrassing that they
did it I think it's a waste of an
episode I think it's a waste of time
I've wasted an hour of my morning
watching it
I'm actually a little bit it is the
Klingon bit that has made me angry about
it I will admit
but it's not Star Trek
it's not
I'm trying like a lot of Star Trek fans
actually to be fair I've tried to come
up with excuses for this series because
we want it to be great we want it to be
the best television out there because
we're trekkies
and it's not it's not good enough
I actually think this season of Star
Trek strange new worlds has not been
good enough
it's back to what we we used to before
they're trying to redo the original
series episodes it's very much of
Roddenberry Star Trek this but they're
just not doing it very well
the season finale is gonna have to be
something quite phenomenon to make up
for a lot of this
but I'm just going to end this video by
saying that episode
was a little embarrassing if you were
Trekkie
for me anyway
that's my opinion
but I'd love to know your opinion
so
in rhyme and song
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think of this episode
anybody comes to me and says that
science fiction and I'm sorry I I cannot
disagree with you enough because it's
not
but I would love to know what you do
think so get into the comments
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also go to patreon.com forward slash
Sidetrack where most of our new videos
appear first and you can see them
without the adverts for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel you even get a free
gift after three months
that episode has really made me angry
but live long and prosper
keep going maybe the finale will be
better
thanks guys see you soon
[Music]